Now one,
no program,
he's actually that easy.
But it's like as far as developed
developing programming environments mean
it's,
it's really made it a lot easier for
people to make you know,
sites like what 2.0 type sites then then
it would have been five years ago.
And um,
as I was saying,
like when the cost of production,
the ease production,
the democratization of production has
really come down.
And,
and that's,
I think,
you know,
something that like this sort of idea of
like democratization of production is,
um,
something that like all mediums,
all media are having trouble with.
And,
and that to me is like the real story of
not just the Internet but about like the
shift from analog to digital is that
we're seeing it becoming with each
passing year cheaper and cheaper and
easier and easier for anyone to produce
anything,
whether it's like,
you know,
a TV show or a radio show or a podcast
or music to make their own music or
create their own,
you know,
online,
newspaper,
so to speak.
I mean,
all these things that are,
it's become so cheap and easy.
And then you couple that with basically
the world's most frictionless
distribution mechanism that,
um,
it's really hard for,
for,
you know,
these,
these media companies which thrived in
the age of mechanical production or
reproduction.
Um,
and I read a lot of valter venue me and
like I know all about this stuff.
Um,
you know,
it's hard for them to really thrive in
that environment and um,
it's,
you know,
they,
they probably should've started
cannibalizing their businesses five
years ago.
I think it might be too late.
It's going to be too late for a lot of
them.
And the reason why I'm getting,
you know,
doing something with music,
which sounds crazy,
it is crazy.
I mean there's no reason why anyone
should get into music business now.
Um,
is that like,
I'm kind of betting that by doing things
that this extremely low,
taking advantage and recognizing,
you know,
these shifts that like we can do stuff
very cheaply,
very efficiently and that we don't need,
like it's like a record label with like
literally without 99% of the other
stuff.
But just like keeping the 1% that's
actually valuable.
Well,
it's more that it's an evolution.
Um,
I mean there are people that I became
friends with on prodigy then I'm still
friends with now and that was 1988 or 89
that I became friends with these people.
And,
um,
but it's funny that they reconnected
with me through my space.
So it's just kind of funny how that all
works out.
Um,
I mean I think that it's,
it's a lot,
you know,
a lot of stuff on the internet is not
necessarily a difference in,
in,
it's not a quiet,
it's not like why annotated Lee
different,
it's more,
it's not qualitative to the different,
it's sort of quantitatively different.
It's like an evolution of something that
happened before and,
and because of broadband and
improvements and web based technology,
I mean,
you can make the experience better and
you can facilitate it and make it,
um,
a lot smoother.
I mean,
it's like,
you know,
Youtube,
you could have done youtube years ago,
more or less,
but what,
what made it possible was,
um,
broadband and so it changed it.
Broadband really changes the way people
interact,
you know?
Uh,
it makes,
it changes the way people interact with
the Internet because it means a lot of
things that were too frustrating to do
before,
like download video.
You know,
you wouldn't want spend a lot of time on
facebook of facebook if every time,
you know,
you wanted to click on a profile page,
you have to wait a minute for it to load
and defeats the purpose.
And a lot of people,
especially young people on facebook and
my space,
we'll spend,
we'll look at like 60 or 70 pages in a
session.
And so,
you know,
they can,
because of that can happen really
quickly.
It's only that they actually do want,
they actually will do.